hello everyone and welcome to skip
rewind episode 4 if you're unfamiliar
with this shoe format basically the ROM
dine is I go through the videos that you
may have missed in the past week a man I
go on to talk about some SCP themed news
that has also happened in the past week
it's always pretty interesting the SCP
community is quite prolific when it
comes to making things so without
further ado let's go over the videos
that you may have missed this week ok so
because of the limitations I can only
put 5 cards per video
you know those wee things in the top
left-hand corner that you can click on I
can only do five of those so before I do
that I want to talk about SCP secret
laboratory the links for these two
videos will be in the description if you
don't know SCP secret laboratory is like
a multiplayer version of containment
breach I didn't know this before I made
the videos but it's based off gmod
breach I think it's called but SCP
secret laboratory is based on the unity
engine and it is supposed to be a fully
fledged iam at the minute it's only in
better as I said but I think it has
amazing potential to be a really good
multiplayer SCP game I think it's one of
the best I've seen out there because I
did try and play the gmod version and it
felt really clunky to me because after
all it's a mod that people are working
on for free so it's still really good
but I think because secret laboratory is
built in the Unity engine and has a lot
more potential to become a more popular
game I think so yeah that's those videos
out of the way if you would like to
watch those gameplay videos and you
haven't watched them go ahead and watch
them if I was to make a recommendation
probably the second one is probably more
worth your time because that's more
representative of what the actual game
is like so there you go
the second video which is the first card
that should be in the top right hand
corner right about nine is the
confinement speed painting that I did of
the character Connor from confinement
this was a
a week after in the pines dropped just
an amazing SCP music video created
animated by the granddaddy himself Lord
bong such a talented guy really funny as
well but he created a character Connor
for confinement as I'm sure you're all
aware and I just did a little speed
painting of Connor it didn't really turn
a 100% how I wanted it to because I was
trying to do it as quick as possible but
even if you want to just skip to the end
and see what the actual finished result
was you can do that too so moving on the
next video is the night before redacted
this is a scp-049 reads that's got
posted on Christmas Eve and not a lot of
people saw it which is kind of confusing
because I thought a lot of people liked
scp-049 content so if you miss that and
you like scp-049 give it a listen and
watch as well because it's kind of
animated at the same time and then after
Christmas I got back into doing SCP
document reads and the first one of
these document reads is SCP 9
this was featured in the music video
which Ian and the pines I'm gonna try
and make my way through all of them but
this was the first of them very creepy I
thought even the artwork that Lord bong
created of the one of the victims of
scp-914 thousand Bigfoot a lot of people
think this SCP is a joke and that's kind
of the point I'm not gonna spoil
anything if you haven't heard of it or
you haven't read it give it a lesson
because it's pretty good it's one of the
batterer SCPs in my opinion anyway and
then lastly we have scp-217 the
clockwork virus this video I tried to do
something a little bit different because
I actually created artwork for the SCP
because it had none it was kind of like
a a Photoshop amalgamation of loads of
different things but I thought it turned
out really well and to boot it's quite
an interesting document to read or
listen to depending on your preference
so check that out if you haven't already
that takes care of my videos for this
week so let's go on to the SCP news of
week so the first piece of news I think
will be useful for people who like to do
the SCP cause plan and not is there's a
company on at sea called space fish
patches and they are creating some
really really high quality SCP patches
so if you're making like a you know a
nine tailed fox costume or an SCP Guard
costume some of these patches will be
right up your street as you can see by
the image they have a really big
selection specifically there's some
versions of the SCP lugu that I think
look really nice so anyway the links
will be in the description if you want
to check their shop white or just check
the image out to see what it's like the
second bit of news is there's an SCP 450
game and the works there's a screenshot
here of what the game might look like
Noom which I think I think that's his
name numa numa krod nm KD his username
on reddit he said in the comment thread
Baloo that the screenshot was just mmm
playing with assets and effects so he
said he does plan to make it but he's
focused on all his efforts on the three
zero zero eighth game which i think is a
good idea because having multiple
projects at the same time it just makes
everything slower so at least whenever
that that games done he can move
straight on to something else that as
equally as interest and so thumbs up for
me can't wait a man the next piece of
news in a related note is news on the
next update of three zero zero eight at
the cool operational update this is
obviously gonna be a multiplayer update
but the this anything that involves SCP
games and multiplayer is always good in
my opinion so it's a pretty cool little
animation I think they're they're
employing a motion graphics guy to do
this because they look really impressive
as far as an ETA Noom crowd has said
it's gonna be available probably the
first quarter of 2018 so we've got a
while DeWitt so just to make everybody
aware you have something to look forward
to in the near future it's not gonna be
next week but sometime the next few
months we're gonna have a multiplayer
version of scp-303
so that's really cool the next piece of
news is kind of weird I don't want to
I'm not saying that the SCP foundation
is real I think if you say that in the
comments section you're either trolling
or you're really really young and don't
know any better
so I'm gonna I'm gonna preface this with
the SCP foundation is not real okay
moving on but this was posted on the
reddit this week it's like a truck with
SCP foundation off-site response written
on the side of it pretty much 100% it's
something he's just a big fan of the SCP
foundation and just wants to dis you has
found him on the side of his car but
yeah it's always cool to get actual
pictures of the SCP foundation leakin
into reality something Schemmel like it
says site 42 on the side is this your
car sure anyway I just thought that was
kind of cool so that's the news finished
I hope this eliminated it's something
that you didn't know I hope to see you
all again next week thanks again for
watching
I'm good bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]